hallo mein name ist luca und ich stelle
euch heute mal wieder minecraft kommen
uns vor ich habe leider nicht so viel
zeit deswegen habe ich heute wieder nur
21 mit am start ich hoffe ihr
entschuldigt mir das nächste woche
kommen wieder drei wir fangen mit dem
erste wir geben zuerst mal wieder in den
chat 1 / gfp command unterstrich block
um den command blog zu erhalten dazu
holen wir uns hier noch einen level
setzen das ganze hin und fügen den
command ein derby zugesandt wurde von m
siemag istein und zwar ist es der
polarbären command gesehen stammend sich
dieses ganze dinge kreiert hat haben wir
hier ein polarbär alte mit hinweise 64
stück ein buch und wir sehen hier polar
bear is bei msi marc stein subscribe to
me on youtube voller mir und twitter
download die resource pack hier
und dieses resource beck habe ich
nämlich noch nicht drinnen soll jetzt
habe ich drin und was ist genauso wie
das default ecken nur dieser eisbär bzw
polarbär den ich hier hin setzte der hat
jetzt eine eigene textur und wenn ich
das ganze beim normalen pack belastete
wer hier einfach so ein schwebender
wolle blog so sieht das ganze im
normalen texture pack aus sehr sehr sehr
komisch deswegen nutzen wir natürlich
das polar bear texture pack und wir
haben jetzt diesen polarbären hier darum
läuft und so weiter und so fort wir
können ihn rein theoretisch noch
angreifen das gibt aber nur aus einer
bestimmten entfernung beispielsweise
wenn ich ganz nah davor stehe geht es
nicht wenn ich hier stehe geht es
wiederum und dann habe ich noch ein buch
polar bear controller kann ich nämlich
sagen ob er entweder locken soll
das heißt der markt jetzt die ganze zeit
und läuft jetzt quasi auf der stelle bzw
mir auch nach hinterher dann kann ich
sagen er soll rennen dann seht ihr schon
was macht er dann cremig schneller sie
total groovy aus dann kann ich sagen er
soll sich hinsetzen war es das hier in
sekunden da steht auch neben das heißt
60 sekunde sich 60 sekunden setzte
niemals allerdings einfach mal 5 damit
ihr das sehen könnt und jetzt könne das
waren keine fünf sekunden lieber
polarbär ich habe jetzt hier einfach mal
noch ein zweiter gespannt weil der
andere einfach nicht mehr aufhört zu
laufen und zwar wenn ich jetzt einfach
mal beispielsweise luft machen seht ihr
schon der schaut hoch und schaut sich
mal so süß wie so ein kleiner süßer dann
gibt es noch die kontrollmöglichkeit das
heißt er steht auf audio
das sei ungesund aus was er damit seinen
kopf gerade gemacht hat normalerweise
später dann nämlich so hoch ich schauen
ob wir hier zeigen kann
nein das ist kein irgendein fehler
begeht dann halt so hoch mit seinem kopf
macht einmal so ich glaube ich wird ein
super bowl hat kim und die letzte sache
die dinge machen können ist einfach
töten dann sind es halt einfach tot das
ist schon alles was mit den polarbären
machen kann die greifen mich auch nicht
anders ich kann so viele schlagen wie
ich will obwohl ich kann mal schauen was
passiert wenn ich im game zu null geht
die über ob das einfach viel zu süß um
mich zu kommt alle hier und jetzt macht
allemal rocker verraten
das ist auf jeden fall nummer 1 von
dempsey maki steil ist aus der
verbesserungswürdig der polarbären
kommen was simples für den start und wir
machen jetzt weiter mit commander 2 der
schon deutlich umfangreicher ist command
nummer zwei ist nämlich von der red
engineer wir kennen ihn aus den anderen
folgen und zwar habe ich den kopf schon
eingefügt druck auf den schaltern wenn
der block oben erreicht wird ist die
maschine auch schon fast fully assembled
und wir sehen dann gleich wenn das ganze
aufgebaut ist auf ich meine dieser seite
kommt gleich ein schiff oder kommt auf
der anderen seite hier sind die schilder
hier ist allerdings nichts wo ich direkt
die items bekomme sondern nicht bekommen
noch eine info im chat und zwar drop on
ground 25 dirt 2 52 vortag 2 52 dollar
dörthe hoppius spencer and diamond
textet rief haben also und es war es
geht halt wirklich nur mit der
bestimmten anzahl an dirt ich hab's
probiert mit 64 ich habe es mit 26
probiert probiert es geht wirklich nur
mit 25
das heißt ich nehme 25 wird eine diamond
x2 europa waren das und noch was war da
sonst noch 33 hopper und zwei dispenser
war es okay dann hole ich mir noch mal
eben noch einen hocker und noch mal eben
zwei dispenser und wenn ich jetzt diese
items hier alle zusammen auf dem boden
schmeißt und die sich zusammen
fusionieren seht ihr schon was ich
bekomme einen free farm altem biss kann
ich jetzt einfach hier hinsetzen und ihr
seht schon dabei
die maschine ist einfach in der
gottverdammten luft aber das ist kein
problem
hoffe ich zumindest jedenfalls können
wir mit der maschine jetzt erst mal
nichts anfangen wir sehen hier
verschiedene sachen beispielsweise in
puts apple inc sie sehen wie es apple
links und hier sehen wir loks und hier
ist halt so ganz normaler output links
aber das ganze ding funktioniert
irgendwie noch nicht richtig dafür holen
wir uns jetzt neben nicht diese daylight
sensoren und davon am besten fünf stück
weil man kann auch ein anbringen aber
dann ist das ganze zeit nicht so
effektiv und fünf quasi das maximum und
wenn dann noch oben die sonne scheint
was ihr da oben gerade sehen wir gleich
das hier so wasser partikel auf dem dort
quasi herum schwirren und fünf von
diesen solar daylight sensoren sind
bildet quasi maximum level of energy
network und jetzt kann ich mir einfach
verschiedene sorten von setzlingen
wollen das heißt beispielsweise etwa 3
auf 6 hiervon welche davon noch einen
davon auf welche und da noch welche und
die kann ich jetzt ganz einfach hier in
denen es in den dispenser reinlegen da
steht nämlich in prozent links die
partie jetzt mich hier einfach mal rein
und wir sehen schon dass die einfach ihr
oben hin platziert werden
wenn denn mal endlich diese scheiß mit
energie port wird aber okay da ist ganz
geklappt und zwar hab ich die zeit jetzt
einfach mal 4500 gesetzt also auf
mittagszeit und jetzt hat das ganze
wirklich funktioniert es war wohl noch
ein bisschen zu früh am morgen
beziehungsweise ein bisschen zu spät
und jetzt seht ihr schon werden hier die
einzelnen setzlingen einfach verteilt
hingesetzt und die fangen jetzt ein
bisschen langsam an zu wachsen das sehe
da schon da sind so grüne partikelchen
rum und da wachsen die etwa quasi
einfach in der
das schnellere geschwindigkeit als sie
das normalerweise tun sollen da wir
allerdings in diesem video keine zeit
haben um zu warten nämlich einfach mal
ein bisschen bei mir
und wer jetzt beispielsweise mal diese
setzling so ein bisschen hochpushen und
zwar werden so nachher die ganzen
anderen setzlinge auch ausgewachsen sein
da werden die ganzen wollen in dem land
stellen das heißt wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise hier noch mal nehme das
war ein super beispiel dass er diesen
dicken baum mit reingenommen habe ich
nehme jetzt einfach mal eben hier noch
so ein dass ich den namen wachsen lasse
den hier lasse ich noch mal eben wachsen
dann lasse ich nur mal den heben wachsen
und vielleicht auch ihren birkenbaum und
dann habe ich hier quasi schon vier
bäumen und ab jetzt ganz gut gesehen und
zwar diese bäume werden quasi
automatisch gefällt ich warte jetzt noch
mal eben darauf dass dieser baum genau
da ist es nämlich passiert und zwar wenn
dieses blaue dann daher geht dann werden
die bäume quasi gefällt und das holz
fällt dann nicht irgendwie an der seite
runter oder bleibt auf diesem dort
liegen sondern wir haben hier zwei
kisten und zwar immer hier selbst links
da sind allerdings noch keine da weil
diese blätter hier noch keine samplings
geglaubt haben sondern die sachen das
holz ist erst mal hier unten das heißt
auch gleich doppelt karten setzlinge ist
sonnig ich weiß woran es liegt und zwar
kommen die setzlinge die runterfallen
kommen hier rein gedroppt kommen dann
hier in die kiste lassen die web links
drin werden hier weiter geleitet in den
input samplings da sehen wir hier ist
schon direkt wieder ansetzen drin
aber der kommt direkt wieder raus und
bildet sich direkt wieder da oben rein
das heißt wir müssen sie nur einen baum
dahin setzen sage ich mal in etwa und
deren selbst dann wieder setzling
gefallen zum beispiel drei stück und die
setzte dann wieder hin und dann ist es
quasi eine automatische baum vom die
ganze zeit und ihr seht ihr schon auto
dann apfel dann haben wir halt hier die
ganzen holz sachen drin und den apfel
und so weiter übrigens eilfeld hierzu
weder dreh denn ich habe immer noch
zahnschmerzen adidas sender challenge
meine ganze ein ganzes zahnfleisch wurde
von diesem dummen zitronen sirup den ich
getrunken ab zerstört ist so eine
scheiße das ist auf jeden fall die
automatische baum fahren von der reith
engineer ich finds mega cool weil man
quasi nur diese maschine braucht in
einen setzling und dann funktioniert
ganz und wenn ihr euch denkt okay ich
möchte mal mehr als nur eine machen dann
könnt ihr auch mehrere davon machen und
zwar können jetzt beispielsweise hinten
noch mal eine machen oder hier auf dem
ich bin im glas gefangen er sagt halt
nur dass die ihm mindestens einen neuen
blöcke abstand sein sollen wenn ihr euch
jetzt denke diese maschine die faktisch
nur noch ab könnt ihr einfach unten
links den kumpels herstellern geht
nämlich direkt alles kaputt und wir
bekommen auch direkt unser team zurück
aber es ist eigentlich mégane ist quasi
durch einmal dieses item holen und dann
ein setzling haben den schmeißt einfach
unten rein und dann habt ihr einfach
unendlich holz für euer leben lang damit
sind wir auch schon am ende ankommt von
dieser folge minecraft common sense euch
gefallen hat will ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen schreibt mir die
kommentare weitere kommen sondern links
zu anderen videos oder whatever schönen
tag bei mir sind es geht sich gerade
scharf